I feel like I moved down in places whoa
it's heart wise annual with 10,000 bits
oh maybe if maybe I should include that
in the YouTube video - oh man
or maybe that will be the beginning of
the next YouTube video which is this
YouTube video yeah it's the sign of Fame
I have so much future planning to do all
these YouTube videos coming up still
waiting for a game this is the thing
about classical tournaments Oh hands up
okay tell me an opening to play Queens
gambit of 19 seconds some of these
openings I don't know of what so we're
opening I want to play something
reasonable let's play I was seeing a lot
of efore suggestions whoa it's talking
with 5,000 more bits okay wait let me uh
let me try and focus here things again
tigey thanks again car wise univille we
have a Petrov I don't want to like play
garbage some people were saying
Halloween gambits but Halloween has
pasts people some people were saying
Italian it's not so easy to play Italian
against Petrov but I can try I'll play
Bishop c4 here Bishop c4 is interesting
move the idea it's actually we could
have a reverse Stafford gambit
because one ideas Knight takes e4 and
then Knight c3 in which I would have the
extra tempo with already have played
Bishop c4 okay so this will be
interesting a slightly unexpected like I
don't think anyone recommended this
specific line but hopefully there will
be lessons to learn and actually for any
for player that doesn't know what to
play against a Petrov I can recommend
Bishop c4 as like an aggressive kind of
venomous option because White's
temporarily down a pawn but there is
there's a lot of tricks involving I mean
White has a lot of initiative here
already I've threaded this I've threaded
this Black has nothing developed so yeah
we're we're at least beginning to have
some fun
also nav wander
thanks for the sub and it's always my
sign when the pawns thinking I will say
that at a very high level this is
considered dubious freud's and this is
why we didn't see this in the World
Championship match
I'm sure it was five Yano playing
playing the black pieces
Fabiana would have been very happy if
Carlsen went into this line I'm sure
he's booked up and it turns out f6 is a
best move which is slightly concerning
hopefully opponents isn't super booked
up okay but we're still gonna have fun
on like even when f6 is played it it's
still a bit awkward for black because f6
so this diagonals open as far as I know
Knight h4 saw the right approach and
okay my one hope is that opponents not
booked up with like although the
computer moves because if that's the
case and I have no chance but the idea
of Knight H for a simple threat of queen
h5 another idea is to play off for it at
some point and just bust open the center
with whites or with blacks King on
Castle and not really going to Castle
anytime soon because like
oh geez oh no what my queen is safe I
don't have anything to say oh no about
maybe oh no my pond thought it it's a
little too late to be regretful what's
happening soon what's about to happen
f6 f6 already played g6 oooh yeah g6 his
best move easy move to find those really
only move to the fund against Queen h5
and now okay now I'm trying to remember
because I've had this position as black
in bullet kings I remember just getting
just completely torn apart by various
opponents oh I think it's f4 immediately
that makes the most sense because I'm
never scared of g5 even though I should
always be scared of g5 because Queen h5
check in taxi poo 71 thanks for the sub
so f4
and very soon I want a castle open F
file here we go
haven't heard that one it's always elite
Scoob oh my gosh whoa it's talking with
twenty gifted Suggs here we gooo I guess
what's happening Thanks taggi and thanks
Oh
also thanks to the the 20 new subs for
existing I could read these names off
while my opponents contemplates my
opponents just has nothing developed
already attacking stuff okay I think
that's enough
errors to keep people entertained new
subs SG SG tryto oh never mind
efore okay before I don't remember being
a move now it might be a move now when I
say I don't remember it being a move
it's like I'm referring to the the
computer evaluations because there is
some point in time I was studying this
with stockfish and I vaguely remember
like d6 Queen e7 but before I guess it
makes some sense I mean some point black
wants to play d5 f5 and have a pawn
center and shut me down so there's some
ideas that initially come to mind I'll
have to hold off reading the sub games
but people can see when they they pop up
one idea is Queen Queen d5 I mean
probably the most forcing move there's
also ideas f5 there's also an AI that 5
idea whenever black takes out Queen h5
check with lots of fun the thing about
Knight a5 I don't think or does it
threaten something actually neither 5
kind of threads Queen d5 because it
takes away Queen e7 and it would be
unstoppable
but I think like neither five just
doesn't seem right black could even play
c6 and d5s coming yeah
so the most attractive move as far as
like everything I've considered is that
five is that five actually has the
threats and I got 5g5 then queen h5 kini
seven queen like the king just gets
dragged into the open and maybe I can
orchestrate some castling with Queen
side checkmate stuff like f5 what does
black - to defend those pawns hit
there's no rock GA time controlling g8
I'm just writing to take twice deef I
guess d5 is a move but f5 d 5 I take if
Bishop takes I take and again Queen h5
let's play out 5 also open up the bishop
so there is I mean mean issues for black
are tactical but it's also kind of
positional to accelerate my my
development further also trying to open
that file ok ok I can still scroll up me
read off these names DT numbers Papa
Bell one of agar tan Lloyds column media
audio smarts Fargas 2 3 5 4 Galen one
one one ladder one anxiety just take a
deep breath and you'll have less anxiety
also drink some tea say routine 5 1 8
scrote a he who come lover 6 9 nathan
b13 coos or ryu matt 3 1 451 Doug
Winslow Trackpad 94
a new in noon mean iam a van Hoffman and
test account please ignore thanks
taggi again for all the subs so many tag
emotes all those subs
have received the tag eat a guitar
guitar emails just use it try to use it
in moderation also can I just take upon
opponent wants to play d5 it could be
getting spicy I'm fantasizing takes d5
and then queen h5 and then I lose a
bishop and then I push upon the King
moves and then I promote make another
queen let's do it okay life is good like
takes takes
oh I'm throwing made into I'm
threatening me into opponents not gonna
let me do it but there's about seven
Keaney 79.5 is meet be quite nice most
expected is d5 second most expected as
takes will see see what happens
but I'm feeling good opponent kind of
walked into the line now suffering from
lack of developments as yeah positions
opening up Queen h5s coming
[Music]
yeah I don't think there's a line on d5
g7 I don't think it's as strong oh and H
that's like a it's an interjection
expressing expressing satisfaction maybe
or tastiness thank you master for the
the resub for four months yeah so defy
of Queen h5 still looking very
attractive trying to protect what that
will do hey auntie was Happy New Year to
you too
thanks again for the sub in a KD so no 7
a KD 707 tried to cheer in the sub
message I guess you can't you can't
cheer and sub at the same time but could
try ok Queen h5 great ride I'm thinking
King d7
huh the bishop is kind of hanging but
okay King g---seven that should be great
for me like just Bishop e2 like it would
keep the pin I want the pawn back too
okay let's play Queen h5 I realized I
only made one cup of tea I forgot to
make the pot I just put the teabag in
the cup I need ashwagandha tea it's like
some Indian sort of spice it's really
good hey hey KD 707 if you try it first
and don't succeed you try again and then
you succeed thanks for the bits
appreciate that yeah this is a massive
threat
I mean black either has to like move the
king or take like what else to do
like all of all of the movies don't
really look that appealing but yeah I
was thinking King d7 Bishop e2 and then
I have the threat of this
there's also King King g7 Queen f5 check
mikeam could move back could also move
this way and then Bishop f4 check
there's Bishop d6 takes takes and then
g7 I lose a queen and then the Queen is
reborn I was a bishop and then the
bishop could be taken there's also a
line King g7 Queen f5 King c7 Bishop f4
King b6 which looks interesting envision
b3 King goes back Queen goes this way I
don't know all the lines should be
pretty good for Heights but black did
win connect for while King D son it's so
funny like this opening black developed
a knight traded it off and only push
pause and then the next piece developed
is a king so now the question is do I do
I play Bishop e2 or do I strike
immediately with the check because both
options look quite appealing I think my
Queen wants to stay here just pinning
and the bishop delivering the check
should be a bit more troublesome for
black
there's also bishop Dave's t5 deserves
some consideration
it's actually kind of forcing because
Bishop d6 is this and then like King c7
looking for the knockout blow
[Music]
yeah that's actually take some time here
takes takes takes so I guess there's two
moves because okay King it gets made it
so there's King c7 or Bishop d6
and maybe they just transpose they
probably just transposed to each other
because I would play Bishop f4 against
both of them and then black would just
play the other move so we get to that
position and if we train I don't really
get much I could Castle queenside Jack I
could play so so let's say this okay we
go down this line King c7 check Bishop
d6 and then g7 so now series Bishop
takes off for but not likely let's say
rook e8 there oh and then my queen
supports the queening square so the
Queen's can then talk to each other if
I'm gonna sack on g5 I want to be extra
certain that it works there's also a
line
I forgot I have a resource not five and
in some of these variations one more
time takes takes takes
King c7 Bishop f4 King b6 doesn't work
cuz I'm in the Queen
so Bishop d6 and then the thought is g7
right away I think one issue is take
yeah there's a lot of Aramis one issue
is takes cuz I make a queen I win the
rook but then I lose a piece and I would
have won a rook for two pieces and my
Queens kinda out of play the reborn
Queen is out of play
so it takes takes takes king c7 Bishop
f4 vision d6 g7 and Bishop takes off for
and key position i Queen c7
Queen c7 Rick still attacks black
probably blocks on d7 and then I take I
really want to make this work but I'm
not seeing a great solution okay now I
have an idea
Oh idea doesn't work it's close to
working idea as takes takes takes King
c7 Bishop here Bishop d6 rook team one
adding more crusher threatening this oh
maybe it does work especially takes off
for I have this move
I wouldn't the Queen sacking a lot of
material but then I should so they have
Queen f7 or no I was like Queen c4 okay
one more time I'm calling through this
so many times
so I stock on d5 Bishop d6 I think it
just gets smashed by knight Knight f5
actually maybe not maybe it maybe this
first so it would just transpose so
takes takes takes Bishop d6 Bishop f4
King c7 and then rook do you want so
then there's so much pressure on the
bishop bishop would take and then Queen
c4 check unleashing the Queen and the
beautiful thing is that after knight c6
I take the Queen either king or rook
takes and then I play g7 and I'm just
queening the next move and I wouldn't
back any material and I've already won
the Queen I'm waiting back even more
material so I think it all works
I'm just gonna do one more check I guess
in this position like does black have
any other options because Queenie seven
out of five is very strong and then same
thing with Queen I mean Queen c7 even
work to you on ideas okay let's go for
this and I'm just checking H shakes g6
as well but then I just take stuff okay
okay while the arrows
I draw arrows so people can hopefully
try and follow I know there's there's a
lot of viewers who are just beginning
the game and need help with notation or
visualizing I'm not sure if the arrows
are actually a help for me or if they're
just added distraction but at this point
it's kind of a habit of drawing them for
the viewers if he doesn't take on d5
then I just I want a very key center
pawn files open and black still has
nothing developed except the king is
kind of developed and this pawn is now
weak most importantly I got rid of
blacks Connect four
I forgot this was this was kind of
Connect four
[Music]
now there's different elements to
calculating like one one element is
visualizing like being able to see see
ahead and see kind of things clearly
another element is like identifying the
right moves and I think in this sort of
sequence in this kind of calculation
especially it was being aware of like
all the resources and kind of seeing the
big picture because in many of these
lines I have to use kind of different
areas of the board like this g7 resource
Bishop a4 resource 41 a lot of things
have to play a role and a lot of it is
like is identifying the forcing
sequences and and finding initiative and
if you can throw punch after punch after
punch then it can it can sometimes lead
to good things if you calculate
precisely what in the chat is saying
that are you saying that I would have to
think about that trip to Thailand it
sounds that sounds interesting wait okay
Bishop d6 so Bishop f4 I'm kind of just
trusting everything I had calculated
moments ago
expecting King c7 king he sovereign
walks into me than one that could be
nice maybe I should I should cover
tigey's trip to Thailand with all the
bits that he's been giving me know
Thailand is a nice place actually was it
exactly it was almost exactly one year
ago I was in Thailand I spent New Year's
last year in Indonesia and then flew to
Thailand I think January 5th or 6 went
to Chiang Mai
we'd schoo yeah
I mean last year I was still living like
a digital nomad lifestyle I was just I
spent like four and a half months out of
the country photo chess a long time no
see photo chess thanks for summing or
thanks for reading s Oh photo yes people
should follow photo chess not only on
Twitch but on on Instagram on all the
platforms take some amazing photos I've
seen photo chesses live feed of the
world rapid in blitz it was really cool
it was like looked like a video game
okay King c7 so we're continuing the
calculation if you're just joining I
spent a long time in this position
drawing many many arrows and this was
kind of the main position that I had
predicted and the thought is to play
rook to d1 it's important not to Castle
queenside because that allows takes with
Czech but with rook d1 I just apply
pressure threaten the bishop and after
this Queen c4 knight c6 rook takes
and then rook takes them in this move oh
but now I'm realizing I'm realizing that
Bishop can just develop and her works
are connected and I can't Queen and
material-wise oh wow no maybe I
miscalculated
I forgot the rooks will be connected
okay to calculate it again rook d1 takes
Queen c4 I mean I can win the Queen I
win the Queen allow this and so so close
to promoting the pawn maybe I can just
take here with 96 ideas
I feel like I was calculating g7 first
but rejected it because of this move I
think that's still yeah I guess that's
still holding up for black it was
actually kind of funny idea just to take
the bishop and then play g7 and then
loose my queen Queen reborn and then I'm
adept exchange that actually might be
the simplest line because other line
looks a little bit murkier up team one
takes oh wait a minute
oh wow okay I've used vine spot huge
vine spots rook t1 takes I I had
considered this initially but I didn't
even say it cuz I thought it didn't work
but I can take the Queen after takes
takes I was so fixated on g7 and just
rejected this whole line because Bishop
e6 but I forgot I could just take on
each seven and black has no good way to
defend against h8 okay rook t1 yeah
that's so simple yeah rook t1 that's
like it's just winning okay I wasn't
looking at the chat so I'm curious if
maybe as some people spotted that I was
so fixated on making g7 work and then
making Queen C for work I forgot to kind
of circle back and consider this move so
in some sense the bishop is still pinned
to the Queen
now the bishops attack three times yeah
this is this is completely over
[Music]
don't flag I have so much time and used
to playing like all this bullets and
buzzer King it's so nice to like
calculate Bangkok opened Bangkok open is
like the biggest tournament in Thailand
but so Baek Hawk open is an April and it
overlaps with Reykjavik open so I have
to choose one to fly in both tournaments
are on my bucket list okay so let's just
actually let's just calculate takes take
sticks
no great checks no tricky tactics okay
oh I completely forgot
oh no I forgot that black doesn't have
to take my rook Oh No I got so excited
black sock and they take my rook blocks
just gonna take my pong my future
beloved Queen dad still have fights and
it's a weird material imbalance to
another blind spot I just I I got so
emotional about seeing such beauty oh
that's unfortunate
what fat tie Oh pad thai oh the pot I
sold in Thailand
okay I can't get distracted by fantasies
of Pad Thai and tea or beer
I have to focus and not miscalculated
more
I'm curious if I should even like take
and take a lot of pawns
I mean material situation which I could
also play this move
wait there's a there's a bunch of moves
to play to attack pawns there's a smooth
there's a smooth and exist move all the
pawns will be attacked the problem is g5
in some cases but I'm thinking okay I
think this is a standout move rook d4
because if g5 then I take and Jeep on
tied down to Bishop Knight will someday
return I was a crook c4 check if needed
yeah I think this is a way to go I don't
think black is saving the pawn so I'll
have I'll basically have a rucking to
pawns for two bishops not sure I'm not
sure who's better here
that's so frustrating to to think that I
was completely winning I played this so
quickly to I should have paused okay but
let's not let's not be regretful about
the past
okay takes I'm just being extra careful
I'm not missing anything I think this is
okay yeah this game will definitely
deserve in the houseless afterwards
because I am curious if there is some
clear-cut wind that wasn't just a
complete hallucination yeah so that's
gonna develop 96
I guess expected I'd like to play this
move the problem is Bishop c1 and then
my pawn and neither attached like a
castle maybe I'm Kal seeing is kind of
interesting
[Music]
oh that's my that's my seating also my
time is running low
maybe the exercise sparks was having a
point using the dome flag emoji okay
castling kingside
it's so laden it's like almost I'm it's
pretty much a game but let's castle yeah
you two people listen to sound Sam knows
what's up
this is gonna be an interesting game for
YouTube
whatever happens Bishop d7 okay Bishop
d7 96 the problem is Bishop a5 yeah it's
not good and I want to remove this
Bishop I really want to make Knight g6
work I mean Knight g6 it just seems like
I'm losing a material there and I could
sack the exchange be down a piece nah
there's rook AJ the threats kind of then
like g3 stuff I'm thinking rookie like
rookie - even g3 here could be
interesting g3 there's something bishop
h3 move
I don't like g3 though the Bishop's
actually quite awkward and f6 is weak
I got five I just move the rook
somewhere that's play g3 I know it looks
kind of weakening because light squares
but I mean there's one one attacking
move I'll defend it's also a weird
situation like it's kind of a love
trapezoid trapezoid diamond it's not a
triangle what do we call this shape some
kind of diamonds type thing I'm not sure
if it's love or hate sir
too many deep words
I did say g3 great wine OD tog II maybe
tog II predicted the future it's a union
yang I like that
the union of ponds and minor pieces ok
well the one of the main points is okay
Bishop e5 looks solid but then they g6
and then I control f5 so there's no
Bishop f5 and the bishop pawn duo should
be destroyed also shark shark
Oracle thanks for subbing and okay that
is possible for Black Tie like sac the
bishop for the pawn but that's that's
the yin and then this would be the yang
and and it's just a trade I think I'd be
happy for that like the rook rook and
two pawns versus knight in Bishop with
f6 being weak good try and play for a
win pretty soon I'm gonna have to live
on the increments but okay 10 second
Kerman is a lot more than I'm used to do
we have 666 viewers that's not a good
sign
but let's not believe in unlucky numbers
okay what to do f5 I guess the problem I
can't move the rock anywhere because
bishop eath or anywhere along the fourth
ring because Bishop e3 and then takes so
I have to move the rook along the e-file
there's really only two moves to
consider link rookie to makes most sense
rookie to take stakes yeah
rookie to
have to be aware of like the alignments
but at least for now there's no Bishop
b5 now I'm threatening I just want to
like trade Bishop four nights if Bishop
moves I win that pawn I guess the
Knights I think there's this smooth 95 I
don't think that works so cuz I just
take and I attack the knight
confusing position I don't know what
site we prefer
like if I can hold on to the bishop hair
then it could be very troublesome Otaki
using another new emote I'll explain
that emote later remind me that emote
will be relevant within a few days thank
you
dreamer here 3x3 I'll have to pass them
on to taggi in the form of pad thai okay
opponent getting low on time I'm trying
to okay I guess I don't need to predict
let's also take here hmm oh this is
decision moment the problem is if I take
here take stakes and a file opens upon
supersolid
if I take here Bishop Aston has to move
I guess Bishop returns f4 that's not so
pleasant
actually if takes takes takes I do have
outside pass here and then work out for
coming
it's rook Jay King H - Ezra chief for
actually a rookie a rookie - okay let's
do this there is kind of a I guess a
theme in end games where it's rook for
two minor pieces and the theme at least
in this position is the concept of the
outside passer minor pieces sometimes
have difficulty defending against
outside pass pawn
and the deeper we head into endgame the
the more powerful that rook can become
especially with with a passed pawn on
the board usually like earlier in the
game minor pieces are preferable because
they can organize some attack no it's
it's not a frozen rosin emotes except I
should probably make oh that would be
interesting emo to make you all do a
photo shoot next time there's a blizzard
and then I'll I'll convert whatever
photo of me frozen into a frozen rosin
emotes okay let's stay focused ah okay
Brooke f4 I think is it's just a great
square for a rook like blockade the pawn
defend upon constantly pressure this
pawn the Knights restricted by my pawn
by my rook by my other basically
controlling all the squares and I can
move towards any sort of action but I
could move here but also the bishops
restricted like everything's kind of
restricted for black block kind of
waiting that move as reasonable I have
to play quickly yeah I guess I could go
to Iceland but wait okay focus time so
Nikes have an actually very clear idea
as if that was a good move by the
opponents I'm thinking c4
no play see for I do give the night of
square but the idea o
bishop bishop c64 could be very
unpleasant
I might have to allow it
yeah let's allow it the idea was see for
us to prevent 95 now I'm preventing 96
which was annoying threats expecting
this and this my plans to put the work
on g5 and then get the H pawn moving
bishops gonna find a very happy home I
have to play this move
now Poland played well to kind of used
to improve the bishop now the Knights
kind of improving I could play before so
I do have a foreign to advantage some
idea of c5 maybe King where should the
King move each to maybe like two g3
I know I know it was complicated I was
trying to calculate this line lines is
like very weird actually the line kind
of keeps going to 95 takes 93 here pawn
takes and then takes I hit the night
nights restricted hears night f2 and
then King III and then h3 yeah I could
move oh maybe I have to go for that
let's go for it no not what I wanted but
it's still interesting
oh I forgot beaches hanging he
alternative I have to go for this oh
dear I think they're here to see Lucy a
fork maybe oh we could just simplify
into a draw I don't really want to draw
but I kind of have to right yeah I have
to I'm down in the night to do this
game's gonna be a journal unless some
really weird thing happens
I mean maybe all I I have there is a
game in the the winter marathon I once
an endgame like even worse than this I
was like down upon so maybe all I'll
test my opponent and like basic rook
endgame I'm thinking we'll just continue
longer I'll see if my opponent offers me
a trough first and then perhaps decide
there's a slight imbalance like this
pawn structure I'll walk the King to b3
I'll try and advance and do stuff with
the rook good packing no no the game and
the game is continuing that the end the
rook end game is just beginning actually
already like considering this and maybe
black will self-made somehow well okay
let's start with King b3
the one thing I'll say like these types
of egg names they look really simple so
many people if you're here for the taggi
bits make yourself known than the chats
if you're here for the chest you can
also make yourself known let's play play
this move before might be coming but
before not really an issue I was gonna
say like sometimes people go wrong in
these end games because they assume it's
very simple and then sometimes unusual
ideas can pop up you never want to just
relax thinking the game is gonna play
itself and my opponents clearly trying
to do something maybe trying to play
against my time wait before wait before
[Music]
wait this is still a draw but now let's
take it's still a draw like black
actually has a very clear way of
simplifying
this is kind of risky way to play for
black wondering if I had I probably
didn't have anything better it's funny
actually like we're about to get to a
situation or either of us could lose if
we make the wrong move but yeah I'm
playing it out I'm not gonna sit except
our leader on holic I'm up upon I used
to be down at night yeah so this is an
issue so if I play King c-4 I lose or do
I
I lose yeah so I have to take the pawn
now it looks like I'm almost losing to
this move but thankfully I have c4 and
yeah do you still want me to play it out
I could play it out to prove my
dominance with extra pawn or I could
offer a draw be civilised opponent
thinking all right I couldn't like if I
really wanted to I could flag and I
would still be a drama I'm just
imagining like people in the YouTube
comments and being being so frustrated
with all these bits but maybe sometimes
people in the YouTube comments don't
understand what bits are I do appreciate
like the the supports that the bits do
support the my my quest for chess
education anyway let's sum let's analyze
maybe soon-to-be right soon to be also
used to be but have to wait a few more
years for that
yeah
so opening wise we can see sock fish
isn't impressed but the the valuation
doesn't reflect how difficult this
position is to play for black and then
before I think is the first mistake from
opponents sure Edith Shaw thanks for
subbing I think like already here I mean
we can check with stockfish I think it's
already quite good for whites yeah so
probably best move is Queen e7 or c6
yeah black has to like really play
accurately and hunker down
[Music]
okay so position was really good and I'm
thinking that okay Bishop takes d5
probably best move
Wow Oh so Brooke t1 so I had considered
taking and then playing g7 and then
convince myself that e1 was better so is
it just taking in g7 yeah I can Queen
here he White's just on material but
then again like I played bass on this
just over Sykes I thought like I thought
my plan would be captured I forgot the
material situation that like I'm not up
anything but I thought like winning the
rook I'd be up something that I had
already sax the bishop on d5
i stock my [ __ ] one off for as well so
yeah that's like castling would have
been bad because then black takes with
Czech and then yeah so we can kind of
see stockfish maybe slightly prefer
black
maybe it could have been worse for me
yeah I'm game
yeah I think I just got outplayed in
that game this whole idea of preparing
this and then this and then this was
quite strong I got really the long time
the guy I was very close to flagging I
thought I was just close to losing here
but thankfully like I have this move so
it's a bit tricky for Black team d6 is
better way to play for a win is black
mana saying could you play g7 115 really
I would probably believe that just so
the value of his brand move 15 g7
I'm trying to remember if I consider
this I don't think I even considered g7
here though maybe I did
g7 I think the issue was after takes
yeah I think I've looked at this briefly
and it's another situation Black has two
minors for a rook and I thought the
Queen is kind of out of play Knights out
of play
maybe I didn't look further enough
because there is Queen g8 coming with
this kind of skewer idea now this looks
playable but this could just be winning
in black survives Queen here checking c6
we'd probably just be a mess we can see
what's doctor says g7 stockfish prefers
my my original intention Queen c4 and
then take and then over them take here
yeah here here here take stakes
the first thing I thought you said okay
White's better in all these lines but
taking here preparing this is quite nice
and there's no Bishop a5 or Bishop e6
yeah now pawn so powerful but g7 right
away
Wow Queen G eights that's what we would
move
that's so weird okay weights maybe
better so now that's so funny suckers
just accepts Queen on h8 defending this
like all these squares are defended and
blacks ready to develop
anyway interesting game I hope people
learn something from a cane mistakes
were made
that's some interesting opening I think
the opening was a huge success my
calculation could have used some
improvement but yeah I'll put that on
YouTube
it was interesting reverse Stafford
gambits some plot twists some taggi bits
I hope you guys enjoyed that you too
people hope you followed Sam's
instructions and I'll see you in the
future